it began when I was a kid and my
grandmother grandma Sonya uh probably
about this high um said to me that
curiosity would be my greatest attribute
and would be a would be a superpower in
my life and all I had to do was just
have the courage to use it I remember
looking at one of my report cards and it
was basically all f's
and she's saying you're going to be
special you're going all the way and
she's telling me how great I'm going to
be but I'm looking at this report car in
her presence and there was just no
empirical evidence whatsoever to me that
that would ever transpire and then out
of college I thought how can I apply
this in a bigger way and I had this one
outstanding professor in my entire four
years at USC and his name was dr. Milton
Walton who was a graduate professor of
abnormal psychology at USC and I'm now
two weeks out of college and I thought I
want to try to get together with dr.
Milton Walden because I was just one of
300 kids in this class and of course
that never had a chance to really
introduce myself so I pursued him unable
to get this meeting so I thought I'm
just going to show up at school again
and wait for him to leave his class and
he leaves his class and I say dr. Walton
I would really like to just have you
know ten minutes of coffee with you I
don't really have any big ask beyond
that other than ten minutes he said but
Brian haven't you already graduated I
said well I have graduated but I just
love to have a coffee with you and he
anyway he agreed and I turned that ten
minutes I expanded it into about an hour
and a half conversation which had
greater value for sure than the year I
spent in that classroom and for over
thirty years actually about thirty five
years I've been doing this every two
weeks meeting a new person in any
subject and other than entertainment so
science medicine politics religion every
art form and I've just been doing it and
six really has expanded my universe
physically and mentally it's created
opportunities that I never even thought
existed in my life or would exist and so
that's kind of the sense of the breadth
of what I've been doing